[mellow music]
♪
- ♪ I TRIED
♪ I TRIED
- [grunting, water running]
[doorbell rings]
WHO WOULD DARE TO INTERRUPT ONE
OF MY NIGHTTIME WORKOUT SHOWERS?
I'M [bleep].
- HEY, IT'S ME, FARLEY.
- I THOUGHT I TOLD YOU I NEVER
WANTED TO SEE YOUR FACE AGAIN.
AND YET HERE IT IS,
YOUR FACE AGAIN.
NO OFFENSE--
YOU LOOK VERY BEAUTIFUL.
- [talk/rapping]
I LIKE YOUR FACE TOO.
PRETTY EYEBALLS.
LOVE YOUR FACIAL HAIR,
YOUR CHEST IS GLISTEN-Y.
- [talk/rapping]
LET ME STOP YOU THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU HERE FOR?
- TO MAKE A DEMO.
I NEED YOU TO MAKE
A MUSIC DEMO FOR ME.
- OKAY, DELL COMPUTER
IN FULL EFFECT,
STATE-OF-THE-HEART
MICROPHONE.
- I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NERVOUS.
- THEN YOU JUST NEED TO "RELAS"
A LITTLE BIT.
- BUT HOW COULD I DO THAT?
I TOLD YOU I'M NERVOUS, STUPID.
- LET ME HELP YOU FEEL
THE SEXY.
- THAT'S NICE.
♪ THAT FEELS SO GOOD
♪ THAT FEELS SO GOOD,
BOBBY ♪
♪ OOH, BOBBY,
OOH, BOBBY ♪
♪ OOH, OOH, OOH, BOBBY
OH, MY GOD! WOW.
IT'S LIKE YOUR KISSES
ACTIVATED MY VOICE.
- NO DOUBT.
- ♪ I FEEL SO
♪ READY FOR LOVE
♪ YEAH
[woman moaning, beeping]
WHAT THE [bleep] IS THAT?
- NO, IT'S NOTHING.
JUST--YOUR BEAUTIFUL VOICE
CRASHED MY HARD DRIVE.
- YEAH, RIGHT.
YOU GOT ONE OF THOSE VIRUSES?
I TOLD YOU.
GET A SECOND COMPUTER.
- I GOT A SECOND COMPUTER.
I GAVE IT TO MY MOM
FOR HER EMAIL.
- OH, HERE WE GO.
GODDAMN, YOU'RE A BITCH.
- I SWEAR TO GOD, FARLEY.
NOTHING'S MORE IMPORTANT TO ME
THAN BUSINESS.
- OH, REALLY?
THEN WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
WITH THIS RINKY-DINK ASS
MICROPHONE?
- DON'T YOU EVER MAKE FUN
OF MY MICROPHONE.
- YOU THINK MARIAH CAREY
SINGS INTO THIS?
- I WISH I COULD BE NICK CANNON
TO YOU.
- WHO DO YOU KNOW?
WHAT DO YOU BRING TO THE TABLE?
- TRIPPY D.
- YO, WHO THE [bleep]
IS THAT?
- TRIPPY D WORKS WITH MGMT,
LMFAO, RUDTF.
- RUDTF?
- MOST DEFINITELY.
[both laughing]
- YOU GOT ME, YOU DEVIL.